dancy nor served as an advisor on the
romney-ryan presidential campaign he
talked to Republican lawmakers before
the polls opened this morning so Dan
what's the temperature not good I mean
the question is will the Democrats win
big or will it would really be a wave
you know do you know if one party wins
more seats that's not a wave a wave is
when every close race breaks in one
direction right now the way House
Republican leaders see it is there's
basically three categories of House
races all right there are the races
there are the seats that Obama won and
Hillary won so take Carlos Cabella
Florida 26 in southern Florida
you know they won by big they wasn't
that district both of them Hillary and
Obama and Clinton one of my big numbers
if the Republican wins that seat early
sign of a wave Kentucky on the other end
which which Trump won and Romney won
2012-2016
Andy Barr in that district Kentucky six
if the Democrats win that seat or at
least sign of a wave and then in the
middle as a seat like in seats in New
York like New York 19 John faff so who's
defending his seat Obama won at once and
then Trump wanted both about six digits
you know 6% age so if you get those are
like three categories of races and Obama
Clinton see that a Republican is holding
an Obama trump seat that a Republican is
holding and then a Romney trump seat
that a Republican is holding if they all
go we got a wave in all those states
Kentucky Florida New York we'll go we'll
learn about early on exactly in Virginia
and Pennsylvania - there's a lot of
remember of races there so let's talk
about the Senate in particular because
it looks like Democrats while facing a
very tougher this if someone said to me
this is the tale of two stories right
Democrats have a lot of ground to make
in the house good roadmap for them in
the Senate different story it's the
worst map they've had since 1930 right
so but how do you see them now because I
hear now the Democrats are feeling a
little confident that maybe they're
closing the margins yeah so first of all
if we could have a bizarre scenario
where the Democrats win the house you
get a wave and Republicans hang on to
the Senate or pick up a seat which that
is only how it happened like twice or
something in the last century so it'd be
very peculiar to your point Republicans
Republican leaders still feel optimistic
that they'll hang on or pick up the seat
just because even if they lose Arizona
and Nevada Nevada they still feel pretty
confident right now
about Missouri Indiana and North Dakota
is there a race or races that you're
watching that will indicate how you
think the evening is gonna go those well
those early states Kentucky Florida and
in New York will tell a lot and then at
the end of the night though at the end
of the night one race I'm very
interested as Mimi Walters Republican
congressman when running for re-election
in Orange County her old district or all
districts basically Orange County Orange
County has been the heart of Reagan
country it's been the heart of
Republican California there are 14
Republican seats in California seven of
them Clinton one in 2016 if Mimi Walters
goes I think all seven goes and all
seven go and I think Republic Democrats
are 37 sorry can't remember which 35th
45 yeah and then we don't want to forget
to what's going to be happening in the
States gubernatorial elections a big
storyline tonight I think is a huge
setback for Republicans I think
Republicans are gonna lose most of the
big gubernatorial races especially in
the Midwest the ones that Trump carried
and made him president and people people
overlook gubernatorial races governors
offices do a lot of party building an
infrastructure building for the long run
it's been very helpful to Republicans
for the last 10 years it helped them
during the Obama years if we lose not
talking so we can just say happy
birthday to you if we're running out of
time
and I don't you know and on your
birthday too
yeah very fast before the for the cake
before the fire yeah Republicans helped
or hurt by the president before we get
results yeah I think that Republicans
will have been helped in some of these
Senate races particularly the state to
the Trump won in 2016 I think they will
really been hurt in the house the
president has done best when he hasn't
made a lot of noise for the House races
so they could focus on the economy per
your last report when the economy who's
been the story the president's approval
rating has gone up and Republican
chances in the house have gone up that
has not been the case last two weeks and
in 2012 it was election day on my
birthday and as we were just discussing
on that election that I had to tell Paul
Ryan that he wasn't gonna win the vice
presidency that was my birthday gift I'm
hoping for a better night tonight I'm
not terribly obvious thanks for bringing
lots of facts an info thank you Dan to
be with you always good to see you
continuous live coverage of the midterm
elections begins on CBS n today at 5:00
p.m. for central and we'll be here for a
prime-time
tonight's special starts at 8:00 7:00
central right here on CBS and the
birthday boy will be back to join us
with that